gato tá esperto M que você pode dar um
fil de energia desencapado PR ele ele
olha fala hum hum hum hum hum b não
cachorro ele sempre tá com cara de eu te
amo você olha pro cachorro a cara dele
tá assim eu te amo você sabia que eu te
amo você olha pro gato a cara do gato Di
eu sei que você me ama é essa a cara do
gato eu gosto daqueles gatos que parece
egípcio sabe uns gatos que não tem pelo
que que tem a cara de assim ó hum cara
de tédio tem um gato tem cara de tédio
tá ligado aquela cara de tédio que o
gato tem assim se ele tivesse uma voz
ele falava assim ó meu Deus chegou o
humando bote reação para mim humando
idiota cachorro o cu do outro
interessante né o modo de identificação
assim de comprimento dos cachorros é
chegar e dar uma cheiradinha no cu do
outro assim ó só para ver mas eu sei o
que é isso aí sabe o que é que cachorro
não é otário Isso aí é um código para
ver se não é outro bicho disfarçado
porque cachorro quer cachorro quando
caga não sujo toba Então tá limpo é o
quê cachorro então ele se encontra já
vai logo atrás e tá limpo galera é
cachorro mesmo é cachorro esse aqui